[Music]
he discovered the Lost Ark he conquered
a Temple of Doom he defeated an army of
evil and now he's looking at a gopher
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull from one of the greatest
adventure franchises of all time comes a
new installment that will make you wish
you were watching The Mummy team-up with
Indiana Jones and the kid from
Transformers to track down the skull of
a stupid alien that should never have
been in this movie in the first place
with this Spielberg and Lucas take a
giant steaming dump on their own legacy
by replacing scary Nazis with scary ants
mountains with mole hills and Karen
Allen with a far less attractive carrot
a litter be amazed that the director who
built a franchise on amazing practical
effects would approve terrible CGI like
these fake fighting monkeys this alien
this jungle sword fight this lumberjack
car not one but three scenes with
Gophers sets that look worse than
legends of the Hidden Temple bands this
shot geez is the same guy that made
Jurassic Park 15 years ago prepare to
feel old as you witness your favorite
childhood hero be constantly reminded
that he's now a senior citizen and to
reach the age where life stops giving us
things and starts taking them away you
know for an old man you ain't bad in the
fight crazy old man and discover the
truth then Lucas and Spielberg and
becomes savvy old geezers their treasure
wasn't gold
knowledge is their treasure a film so
lazy it reuses the same over-the-top
sound effect so boring this backstory
sounds more interesting he was mi6 when
I was an OSS we did 20 30 missions
together in Europe in the Pacific so
disappointing its best moments are the
references to the previous movies
[Music]
and so cartoonish it shows that a
refrigerator will protect you from a
nuclear bomb are you kidding me starring
Harrison bored Gandalf the bed Vladimir
Putin cat blanket et and lucky to be
here
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull five years later and I
still want a refund make sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers and
check out last week's episode the Django
Unchained action figures are
discontinued but we got one and took it
to South Central LA five easy payments
of 1995 ain't nobody got time for Dad I
did not hit her it's not true it
supported I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark